so um what i'm not going to tell you
tonight about is how to live longer but
i am going to tell you how to make it
seem as though
you can you've lived longer and and that
is by seeking novelty so what i'd like
actually what i'd like you to do is
anybody here who's wearing a wrist who's
wearing a wristwatch i'd like you to
take your watch off and put it on the
other hand
yes
now this sounds stupid but in fact what
happens is we automatize most of our
lives i mean almost everything we do
we're training ourselves to become
really automatic about things and the
problem with that is that time
disappears because you know you just you
look at your watch see what time it is
it's a totally natural thing it's like
when you're driving home um from you
know the first time you drive to your
work and back the very first time you do
it it seems like it takes a really long
time but after that it starts becoming
really automatic because you've
automatized it time shrinks to zero i
mean you've all had this experience
right the first time you drive there you
think wow this is foreign after a while
it takes nothing okay what i'd like you
to do is drive a different route home
tonight make sure that you go a
different route home and try to do this
every day i try to do this every single
day just take a different route over to
work so that i can get some of my life
back so that i'm not an automated robot
um go home tonight and rearrange your
office whatever's going on with your
office just rearrange it so you can see
things differently and you know of
course coming to things like long now
foundation events
allows you to inject novelty in your
life and so things seem to last longer
and when you look back at the end of
today it'll seem like uh you know richer
than normal tuesday and you'll have
lived a little bit longer so the more
novelty you seek the better off you'll
be there